هذا فقط في CNN، مسؤولو الدفاع الأمريكيون
يطلقون هذا الفيديو، ألقِ نظرة، هذه
طائرة مقاتلة صينية تقترب على بعد 10
أقدام من قاذفة قنابل أمريكية من طراز B52 كانت تحلق
فوق بحر الصين الجنوبي، لذا ناتاشا آه،
ما الذي تسمعه أكثر من المسؤولين
بشأن
هذا البئر بوريس  لقد كانت هذه مكالمة قريبة حقًا،
وهو أمر
يقول مسؤولون دفاعيون إنه يحدث
بانتظام متزايد فوق
بحر الصين الجنوبي، حيث يقوم الطيارون الصينيون بما
وصفوه بالمناورات العدوانية والقسرية
ضد الطائرات الأمريكية التي
تحلق في المجال الجوي الدولي في تلك
المنطقة وفي  بيان
القيادة الهندية آه قالوا أن هذه
الطائرة بالذات كانت تحلق آه
بسرعة مفرطة غير منضبطة أمام
قاذفة القنابل B-52 وعلى مسافة 10 أقدام منها، مما
يعرض كلتا الطائرتين لخطر
الاصطدام، لقد كانت دعوة قريبة للغاية
لوضع الأمر في نصابه الصحيح  يعتبر الجيش الأمريكي أن
مثل هذه الاعتراضات
خطيرة عندما تكون على بعد 50 أو 100
قدم من الطائرة الأمريكية، لذا فإن 10 أقدام
قريبة جدًا بالفعل